hola internets I am Matt Welch with Nick
Gillespie we are here on ask a
libertarian Day 2012 partly to promote
our newly out in paperback book at the
Declaration of Independence the next
question comes via email Andrew Feist
asks penn jillette christopher hitchens
and some reason writers advocate or
advocated in this case libertarianism as
well as defend atheism are the two
associated with each other in some way
could libertarians be stereotyped as
secular conservatives Nick I like the
idea of secular conservatives but there
are secular conservatives out there
people like Heather McDonald of the
Manhattan Institute for instance I don't
think that libertarians have to be
atheists there is a fair amount of
overlap I think where libertarians and
atheists agree is certainly on the
whether or not the state should support
particular religious institutions I
don't think it should I don't think you
know I take my lead in that from Roger
Williams the great religious center in
colonial America who wrote the first
argument for a fully secular civil
government in the English language he
was a hardcore religionist he was a
Puritan he founded the First Baptist
congregation in America he wanted the
state to be out of religion because he
was afraid of with polute religion
not that it would pollute the state but
it's the same thing so I think that's
where religion any libertarianism
atheism come together is in that idea of
a secular state which then allows free
people whether they're atheists or
religious to create the communities in
the worlds that they want there's
certainly a pathway into libertarianism
through atheism through scepticism which
is very strongly associated but I for
one have never really understand stood
why anyone would see a dissonance
between libertarianism which wants to
shrink government to its lowest
acceptable size or to in order to
embrace tolerance we talked about this
along the book the bigger the government
is the more it's going to offend your
values one way or the other one of the
bedrock principles of kind of the modern
enlightenment is freedom of conscience
that's what created of all things
banking secrecy and prosperity in play
like Geneva in Switzerland and it helped
us very much here in the United States
of America
I see no nothing incompatible between
being strongly religious and being
libertarian and and that's kind of the
whole point of the exercise its
tolerance we'll be back with more ask a
libertarian 2012 in just a few minutes